Wonderful. Okay.
Sergio Fogel, thank you so much
for being on my show.
Good afternoon.
Good afternoon. Good morning for me.
Good morning.
Yeah. So, how are you?
I mean, you're in Uruguay now.
How is everything with covid?
Oh, this is like an island.
We have very very few cases.
Not a single person right now in hospital.
Wow. Okay.
That's amazing.
Okay. So, what I love about this
is that, this is actually
going to be showed in a few weeks.
So, this is always a fun test
to see how things are now.
And then in a few weeks
when this gets  published to our page,
we're gonna see what actually happens.
But let's be optimistic
and see that everything is fine.
I'm going to bet that when this show is aired
we have zero cases.
Incredible.
Funnily enough, or actually not funny.
Pretty sad.
I had a show
with an entrepreneur from Israel
about a month and a half ago
when there were zero cases.
And he said,
"Yeah, everything is fantastic."
"It's great."
And then I said,
"Well, let's wait and see what happens."
And the show is gonna air this week.
And the first sentence is that
and I say it on the show.
Well, let's be optimistic.
But obviously we know
what's happening in Israel now.
So, we're gonna give it another try.
Sergio, I want to spend as much time
as we can talking about emerging markets.
You're an expert in digital, in FinTech.
And you're one of the most renowned
innovators and entrepreneurs
of Uruguay and Latin America.
A limited partner at J-Ventures,
where we work together.
So much is going on.
You're dealing with
one of the most incredible industries
and one of the most fascinating industries
because you're actually dealing with
revolutionizing people's lives in the way
they interact with businesses and consumers.
I traveled to Mexico last year
with one of my best friends from Stanford.
I noticed how the credit card revolution
and digital banking revolution
is just starting out.
It was incredible.
Please tell me a little bit more about you
and what is dLocal?
Okay. So, where do I start?
Let me first tell you a bit about myself.
I was born here in Uruguay.
I [--]
I wanted to live in Israel
when I was 20 years old.
Study tech in Technion.
Worked for IBM.
Then, I went to do my MBA
at INSEAD in France.
Very international school.
Yeah.
And then for family reasons,
we wanted our kids to grow
near their grandparents.
So, with my wife, we decided
it was very very tough decision.
We decided to move back to Uruguay.
But we felt all the time
very very attached to Israel
where we lived for almost 10 years.
And because of INSEAD,
we were always very very international.
We just love to travel.
And these two are really
different people and cultures and so.
Yeah.
So, after us team,
working for a large companies,
we set up our first venture together.
My wife and myself.
So, I'm going to give you
one big piece of advice,
never do a company with your wife
or a loved one.
Because you put too much at risk.
It was a very very bad idea.
I've heard that quite a few times.
Don't mix the two things.
Also with best friends.
Don't start a company
with your best friend.
That's a good idea.
So, first company was a failure.
Then my second one,
it was a telecom company,
voice over IP Company.
Which we started back in the year 2000.
It's still running very very small
because who we use as voice over IP.
We did a long distance
international phone calls.
So, I guess no one does international
phone calls anymore.
And then 12 years ago
we started AstroPay,
which from that company,
we spun off a dLocal.
But before you tell me what these are,
I want you to tell me a little bit
about the market.
Latin America,
hundreds of millions of people.
Coming from Israel
and from North America,
it's a different market.
It's a different lifestyle,
different mentality.
What is happening in terms of FinTech
and the way consumers are interacting
with small businesses
up until AstroPay
and dlocal come into the market?
Okay. So, first of all,
you need to take into account that
there is not a country
called Latin America.
It is very very different.
You go to Brazil
that you have one country.
You go to Colombia,
it's a completely different country.
You go to Argentina's, it's completely
different country and regulations.
Right.
And when we talk about FinTech,
a regulator spirit
play a very very big part.
Of course.
So, you go to Brazil and you'll find that
almost everybody has a credit card
or a debit card.
But you go to some other countries
and you see that
credit card penetration is quite low.
Right.
Now, something that is quite common
to all of these markets,
not only these markets.
We also work in countries
like India or Indonesia or Africa.
Something that happens is that
you see many many countries  where
a credit card penetration is very low,
and they are completely leapfrogging
their credit card
and going straight to wallets.
Straight to  digital wallets.
Yes.
So, the biggest case,
a greatest example, is actually China.
You go to China.
I was there a late last year
and nobody is carrying a wallet anymore.
So people, it's the mobile phone.
You go to a restaurant,
you pay scanning your QR code.
You go to a store,
again, it's WeChat Pay everywhere.
Yeah.
Maybe AliPay.
But it's all,
Incredible. Yeah.
Now,  the pain that we come to solve
is that all these people with this,
actually all of those countries
they have some preferred payment method
because everybody is paying.
And in many cases,
people are going out of,
I will go away from cash.
Yeah.
In some places,
people pay scanning a QR code.
In some places they give
a debit card, a credit card.
In many many cases it's a credit card,
but it's not Visa or MasterCard branded.
So, you go to Argentina,
you have many people with card
called [--].
If you go to Mexico and people pay
with them with cash,
they like to go also and pay cash.
You go to India,
you have all they say E-wallets.
It's all good for the consumers
because the local businesses
accept those payment methods.
But when an international merchant goes,
we call merchant to actually
anyone who accepts payments.
Right.
Our company at once
we sell into these markets
and we have to go
in very very big markets.
You go and you sell into those markets
and you find that people either
do not want to pay with a credit card
if they have it,
or they cannot pay.
So, let's give you
another classic example.
You have the Ridesharing service
who wants to penetrate into a market,
let's say, into a country in Latin America
that there is a very low penetration
of credit cards or something of that sort.
And all of a sudden they're stuck
because they are used to getting payments
through your credit card.
And if the country
doesn't have credit card,
then it doesn't matter
that you have the drivers and the cars
because you can't accept the payments.
And then here you are coming in
and you're saying,
"Okay, let's think of a creative way
to bridge this gap between
the local and international."
Exactly. You nailed it right in the middle.
So, that was a great example.
When Uber came,
it was the first Ridesharing company
to come to the region.
They came and they saw that
most people couldn't pay.
So, many people went to the bank
and they got their first credit card.
Many of them got debit cards.
But then what you find is that
debit cards in most of these places
are not enabled for e-commerce.
So, then we came in and what we did was
we enabled Uber both to accept payments
from the riders and also to,
But also pay the drivers, right?
Also pay the drivers. Yes.
And also accept payments from the drivers.
Because what happened was that
at one point we said,
"Okay, let's allow the drivers
to accept cash payments."
Okay.
So, I think the very first place
where they try it to,
I may be wrong, but I think it was Peru.
In Peru, you could pay the driver in cash.
But then at the end of the week,
the payments was reversed.
Instead of paying the driver,
you need to collect
the commission from the driver.
Incredible how similar services
have to make these adaptations
for the local culture norms
that they have.
Because here in,
imagining in California going into an Uber
and trying to pay them in cash,
it's unheard of.
What happened was that
the moment they started accepting cash,
the sales are actually,
the rise went through the roof.
Of course.
And sometimes in many many cases,
it's a very big differentiator.
You want to accept more payment methods.
So, it's a competitive advantage
against your competitor.
But how does dLocal
actually make that adjustment?
How do you mitigate between the two sides?
So, let's say you go to Peru or Uruguay
or some other country
and Uber wants to come in,
low credit card penetration,
how do you deal with that?
Okay, first of all,
we are integrated today
with over 300 different payment methods.
Wow. I didn't know there are so many.
Sorry?
I didn't know
there are so many payment methods.
There are more.
So, each one of our customers,
our customer called the merchants,
which is the companies.
They decide which type of payment methods
they want to accept.
Of course, there are different fees
for different payment methods.
So, you have a different networks
and local credit and debit cards
and fund transfers and more of it.
And there are literally thousands.
So, when they go into a market,
we work together.
We have a team of what we call
technical account managers
that are engineers that work together
with the customer and we decide
what is the best integration to use.
What is the best payment method
for each particular customer.
For instance, if you are a Netflix,
It is a subscription model.
So, you want a payment method
that you can pull money from the accounts.
You don't want the person
to opt to go and pay with cash.
Maybe you do want,
but if you want the customer to pay in cash,
maybe you want to charge them
every three months instead of every month.
Right.
You need to find that.
And it's very important
that we actually know
each one of those markets.
We have people on the ground
in each one of the countries
that we serve.
You're saying you have people
on the ground in each of these countries.
So, how many people are involved
with dLocal right now?
We are around 280 people now.
Wow.
We're growing very fast.
We'll be over 500 there by next year.
By next year?
Yes.
That's incredible.
Okay. So, now the  given question is
what is it like to run
such a fast growing company
at emerging markets?
I mean, during covid most people are firing.
You're doubling your size within a year.
Yeah. Since covid started we've hired,
I don't remember the exact number,
probably around 30 people.
It's very challenging to bring people in
when you cannot be face to face with them
Of course.
The culture, it is hard.
For me it's very easy because
I'm no longer a CEO of the company.
We have a CEO who is much younger.
He lives in Israel, by the way.
But it is very very challenging.
We have lots of very young people.
Our CEO is I believe 29 years old
I'm not sure if he's 30 yet.
But isn't it challenging
that the leadership team has to,
when you're thinking
of a new market to enter
or the new adaptations you have to make
to different emerging markets.
You have to really understand
their culture.
You have to be sort of,
you need to be local, right?
dLocal, you need to be local
to that market.
So, how do you mitigate this,
the fact that the leadership team
perhaps is from Israel or is like from
different places in the world,
and all of a sudden
they have to make strategic decisions
based on an emerging market
that they don't necessarily
empathize with?
We traveled a lot.
We have local people.
Probably the most
challenging market for us,
we say China actually.
And what we did in Chinese,
we recruited a team over there.
Of course, we started with one key person.
But we recruited a team
of around 15 people.
And we sent a few people
that were working with us for a long time
which are living in China.
So, we try to mix the company culture
with the local culture.
So, they both worked together.
It's not easy. This is quite a challenging.
But again, we need to have,
we do have local people
in each one of the markets.
Because that's the only way
that we can really understand
the markets.
Amazing. Okay.
And we get together once a year
with all the team and
we work very hard
on the character and interaction
between the people.
Okay. Sergio, talked to me
a little bit about
entrepreneurship and innovation
in Latin America.
What is the scene like?
Where is it headed?
And what are some of the most
exciting opportunities that
I could be excited about
as a young entrepreneur?
Let's say, if I want to enter this market
and to make an impact,
a good impact on the market as a whole.
Well, first of all,
I'm a very firm believer
that entrepreneurship is,
It's everywhere.
And actually,
the more challenging the environment,
the more entrepreneurship you have.
You go to, I don't know,
you go to places like India, for example.
And everybody needs to be entrepreneur
because otherwise,
even I would love doing
some basic tasks
that in the US are so simple,
requires you to be creative
and find your way to work.
Definitely.
So, I think that entrepreneurship
and innovation happens everywhere.
It's no longer something
that comes out of Silicon Valley.
And they think that post covid
after companies got used
to hiring remote.
The moment that your hiring remote,
the border doesn't mean anything anymore.
Nothing.
If you're going to hire a remote,
the person can be sitting in Sunnyvale,
or New York, or in Argentina.
It doesn't matter.
So, you expect this to accelerate
the productivity of the markets
that until now
they didn't have access
to a lot of these companies
because of geography.
Now, the engineers over there
and the people who are able to work in tech,
they can work and they often work
at cheaper prices, right?
Actually, I mean,
doesn't have to be cheaper prices.
But as a company
it opens the whole run.
And there is talent everywhere.
Everywhere, right.
And for every, I don't know,
for every Uruguayan
that is working in the valley,
there are a 10 other Uruguayans
that are as talented,
and that they don't want to leave.
No. Of course.
And when I mentioned the cheaper prices,
I meant not only in the sense of,
here the my friends are paying
$2500 a month rent plus $20 a meal
three times a day to just to eat.
You go around the world to any place.
It's not the same price.
So, in order to have a similar lifestyle,
you don't need to get
an entrance salary of 130, 140K
as an engineer.
Of course. Yeah.
Right.
And so, back to your question.
There are many many exciting things
happening in Latin America.
FinTech is one of them.
Banks here are very very old fashioned.
Very inefficient. And so,
in all the different areas of Fintech,
there are many things going on
in payments, in lending,
in insurance, you name it,
There are things happening.
Again, as I said before,
in Fintech in particular,
regulators are very key player
in that ecosystem.
So, and they are starting to see
that at the end of the day,
they need to provide consumers
with more options.
Being careful, of course,
because you want to make sure
that there is no money laundering
or anything bad in bank.
So, that's one area.
Everything cross-border is super exciting.
I am an investor
in a cross-border e-commerce company.
And again, with covid sales are going
through their roof.
It's amazing what's going on
in that market.
And there are many companies
that are doing software development
and testing for a current role.
Sorry about that.
No problem.
What else,
[--]
There's a lot going on.
Essentially you have many many companies
that are clones of US company.
I've seen that as a trend
that a lot of US,
a lot of these emerging markets,
they're looking at this
successful innovations of the US
and they are making a local adaptation
of them into their country.
But Sergio, before we leave,
I wanna thank you again for your time.
20 minutes always go by so quickly.
I always learn so much
from these incredible conversations.
But I have to ask
the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
I would say
I'm very Curious.
International.
And Entrepreneur.
I love it.
Curious international entrepreneur.
Sergio, thank you very much
for the inspiration
Thank you for everything
that you've taught me.
And good luck with covid.
And I hope that it will continue
to be zero cases
also when this is published.
I really hope so.
Really really hope so.
Take care
Thank you very much. Bye.
Bye.